hey guys and welcome back
um so it seems like I'm still here in
Sydney Australia hence the infrequent
posting but let's go ahead and get into
another video so I've been kind of
debating you all for a while now saying
that I was going to cover all of the
distributed systems topics in this new
series and I haven't really been doing
so
um and that's for good reason in my
opinion I think that it's really
important that we kind of slow down and
take the time to understand everything
that has been happening on a single
database node before we make it even
more complicated by talking about a
bunch of database nodes so hopefully you
know by actually slowing down really
diving into the weeds a little bit we
can get these Concepts down a little bit
better and then I won't have to answer
so many goddamn questions in the
comments and waste my own time so
without further Ado let's talk about an
introduction to database for application
this is pretty much the most important
possible Topic in distributed systems
so yeah let's get into it okay so I'm
back again with the trusty iPad so let's
start talking about replication and kind
of what that means so for you beginners
let's go ahead and start this out with a
very simple scenario I am the owner of a
website and this is kind of what my data
setup looks like right I've got it all
drawn out so we've got one server over
here we've got one database and then
we've got let's say five different users
so these three are going to be from the
US and then we've got Australians over
here as you can see other side of the
planet the Earth is in fact flat so keep
that in mind so like I said we've got
one database right one server very
simple five users what if one day I'm
going ahead and walking in my apartment
with my one database and I trip and
spill my coffee on this database well a
few things are going to be problematic
for starters one what happens to all of
the data that I had on this machine well
if I'm able to restart it and it just
powered down for some reason okay fine I
don't lose my data but I do still have
some some down time right now all of my
users aren't going to be able to use my
server and as a result my application is
going to stop making money but what if
the data does get corrupted hard drives
break pretty frequently you know besides
spilling coffee I might just come around
and eat one and as a result you know
it's pretty easy to lose your data so
literally just having one single disk
where that's all stored is a pretty poor
idea and then even besides all of that
there's some performance concerns as
well like I mentioned I have these two
idiots over here for whatever reason
they're living in Australia I don't know
why anyone would do that and as a result
they're super far away from my database
which will be conveniently located in
the United States so all of the requests
are taking forever even more so another
problem is there might just be a ton of
users and if there's so many users just
having one database to handle all of
those user requests user reads and user
rights probably isn't sufficient so
let's go ahead and move on and we'll
talk about now what life is when we do
replication so before we can even talk
about what life with replication
actually is we have to talk about what
replication means basically for now
let's assume it's just going to mean
many databases
and what many databases means is many
copies of that data that we care about
on our database so yeah you can
replicate other things and we certainly
will later in the series but for now
we're only going to talk about
replication as it pertains to databases
so again we've got our server over here
we've got our database as like our
cylinder looking things and then over
here you know we've got our Americans
we've got our Asians so we'll call this
uh basically
um you know what no this will be Europe
and this will be Australia or APAC
and so as you can see now all of us have
different servers and different
databases and so the nice part about
that is a few things one we have
redundant data which means no lost data
if every single one of these databases
has its own copy of all of the data from
our website it means that if one of them
were to go get taken out we could all
route our request to the other databases
which is really nice
another thing now is that we have
increased database throughput the reason
for this is that all of my American
users get to use one database all of my
Australian users get to use another and
then all of our European users get to
use another so effectively we've
increased our database throughput by
three times just by allowing everyone to
use their own copy of the data obviously
this is going to come with some caveats
but we'll discuss those later and then
of course now we can allow Australians
to have basically a database that's
closer to them so not only is there
increased database throughput by virtue
of having more databases but also we can
geolocate our data centers closer to
certain users so that they can get
better performance so again screw
Australians but fair enough we'll give
them a database so that's really nice so
before we even you know go into
basically certain types of replication
that you can do with your database I
just want to you know quickly put an
informative warning on this video I'm
not going to get too deep into the weeds
here this is an introduction the next
three videos are going to get quite a
bit deeper but we are going to go
through some of the basics of how you
actually replicate data from one
database node to the other
so first we're going to talk about
synchronous replication versus
asynchronous replication so thinking
it's a replication is basically the
following we've got our one guy over
here this is our client and we've got a
couple of databases so let's say the
client writes the first database saying
X is equal to four just some key value
start and then the first database says
okay I agree X is equal to four you're
good to go
then what's going to happen now is the
first database has to go ahead and
forward this request to the second
database because the second database
needs a full copy of the data so it's
going to go ahead and do that and then
the second database says okay X is in
fact equal to four now what's going to
happen is basically once the the client
receives word from both databases that X
is equal to four we know that this right
is considered valid and basically other
clients who did not in fact do the x
equals four right can start reading the
new value of x this is known as strong
consistency basically meaning that you
know the second I do a write I'm not
going to consider it valid until every
single replica has a copy of that data
in contrast we also have asynchronous
replication where the first thing I
would do when I'm making a right is go
ahead and perform the right hear back
from my database but then from there on
the database can actually consider that
write valid in the background the first
database is going to asynchronously
replicate x equals 4 to the second
database but in the meantime it's still
possible for another client to go ahead
and read x equals three if three was the
old value so what this is known as is
eventual consistency the main point
being here that in strong consistency
it's not possible to read stale data
where stale data is I guess data that
would be considered old right we know
that x equals 4 is the proper value but
in an eventually consistent model the
thing that's going to happen is it's
still possible for other clients to read
older pieces of data because we didn't
require the second replica to have to be
completely updated the second the right
came in so this comes at a cost
obviously with strong consistency which
is that well rights are going to take
forever right because now we have to
write to two databases instead of one
and in my example from before that means
every single American is going to have
to write to the database that's in
Europe that's going to have to write to
the database that's an APAC and these
rights are going to take a while to
propagate so in reality we don't really
see strong consistency use too much
there are cases where we do have to use
it because stale reads are unacceptable
but in a lot of common modern web
applications
basically eventual consistency is the
norm and we'll talk about ways to kind
of Be Clever with it to try and avoid
getting a lot of stale reads okay so
that is basically one kind of concern
which is you know kind of when do we
actually do our replication do we do it
immediately do we do it in the
background but more importantly another
important part of replication is
actually how we replicate right so we
know that we're going to have one
database which is going to receive a
write and it's going to pass all of that
information to other databases which
need to make a full copy of it so there
are basically three ways that you can do
this and we're going to talk about the
trade-offs of Performing every single
one of them so the first thing is a
pretty easy option we just take all of
the SQL statements or if it's a nosql
database whatever other statements are
kind of going into the database and
copying them directly to our replica
database so for example if we have the
command insert row Jordan you know we
could just copy that over however there
are some pretty obvious issues with just
copying SQL statements which is that
some of them are non-deterministic so
for example if we were to use the
command time.now it means that you know
the original right result of time dot
now is going to be different than the
result of the replica time dot now and
we don't want write conflicts that is
very unacceptable they're hard to
resolve and it's going to cause a lot of
pesky issues down the road when you're
trying to read data that's unacceptable
so for this reason just exporting SQL
statements tends to be unacceptable
another possible option is using the
right ahead log so we've spoke about the
right ahead log plenty in the past and
basically all it is is saying at exact
byte values what you're going to be
writing at a certain point of time it's
just a sequential logon disk so for
example you know in memory address or
rather a disk address 0x0 AFF write the
word Jordan
so this could work and in fact it's a
pretty good implementation however it
does have some fundamental issues which
is that not all of our replicas are
going to be running the same database
software for example I might be running
one instance of MySQL and I want to be
replicating that to a postgres SQL
instance maybe because in postgres there
are certain reads that are a little bit
more optimized and we want a copy of the
data formatted that way so that we can
read from it postgres is going to look
at 0x0 AFF and say what the hell am I
doing with this I don't use this memory
address so why do I need that so for
this reason right ahead logs can be
pretty useless when it comes to
replication which ultimately leads us to
our last and final solution which is
what's often done in practice called a
replication log so a replication log or
a logical log basically just says at
what id to perform the right because
every single one of these SQL databases
is going to have the concept of
basically an ID in a row so as long as
you say you know at id1 put Jordan with
an attractiveness of 10 and an id6 put
them name of tech lead with an
attractiveness of six every single SQL
database is going to understand that and
so it's obviously going to be very easy
to then go ahead and send those changes
over the network from a mySQL database
to a postgres database obviously it does
come at the cost of having to create
this logical log because we already have
a right ahead log but we don't have a
replication log we are going to have to
make one and in theory that should add a
little bit of extra overhead on each
right but hopefully for the most part
this introduction to replication does
make sense the general gist of it is
literally creating extra copies of your
database data it allows for more
throughput for all of your users it
allows for durability in the event of a
crash or an idiot like myself spilling
coffee on the database and of course it
allows for the possibility of placing
certain databases in regions such that
they can serve certain users even better
so overall for any big application any
Google or Facebook or anything like that
replication is a complete must-have
there's no way in hell that you would
possibly have a huge company that relies
on data without completely replicating
that data many many times over so with
that being said guys I hope you enjoyed
the introduction I will speak to you
guys in the next one and we'll dive into
this quite a bit deeper because there's
a lot to unpack here